testa di cazzo ti odio la famiglia ti
ammazzerei madonna come me la sono vista
brutta
no basta bella questi ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono bravi j
oggi siamo dati su twitter mi chiama
dall'altro con vaghi perché vuol dire
banane in tedesco che sono le mie
bellissime skin jewels stairs che ansia
cos'è staskin staskin ragazzi mette
l'ansia in una maniera che non avete
idea e bellissima sembrati pool un'ombra
ok note carmi tra i ragazzi che siamo
partiti bene siamo partiti benissimo ma
è curatissimo lei sono miei testa di
culo sono miei vaffan cuore perché non
[ __ ] continuamente può raga io
allora io sta cosa qua me la porterò
nella tomba sto fatto che mi devono
[ __ ] i punti quanti nervi mi darà
una vigilia dai ma come si fa a essere
così deficienti una doppia shock lance
con la skin di clash su slitte rio in
quel caso allora clash of trans che
sarebbe l'ideale è perfetto non sta
faccia poi tutto fiero il culo in culo
noi colato un altro dai e vabbè ci sta
ci sta fermi nocivo vero madonna non è
non erano meritati perché si era
schiantato lui comprendo non ce la
faccio scattato grandissimo ti adoro zio
ti ha ucciso però ti adoro quanti punti
ci sono a caso a classimo camino thomas
perché sto inglobando un tizio a caso
non ce la faccia ce la faccia ce la
faccio e stupido e stupì poteva uscire
quando volevano n'è uscito e vabbè mi
spiace fratesi stupido che ora che
abbiamo iniziato da dio
questa abbiamo veramente iniziata da dio
veramente iniziata da dio sono veramente
un fuori circo ed altro cola cola skin
dvd di clash of l'ansa a carissimo
porterà culo clash of class non si sa
che non riesco a capire bene dove clash
of trans decimo non riesco a capire bene
dove dove la testa quindi sono
svantaggiati simo potrei sbattere da un
momento all'altro ok perfetto grazie
cazzo vuoi fare tutti grati sono stupido
cazzo ma posso essere così deficiente ma
vaffan
ma perché mi si torna sempre indietro
quando muoio porca eva lercia andato
così bene stava in classifica minchia
avevo sempre ma sempre moglie o non c'è
verso ma mai nella vita c'è vera vedere
ragazzi di proviamoci ai morta di cassi
cosa per perché i solo perché voglio
solo sapere ho ucciso io fortissimo
norcal accalai da tutti i punti mi hanno
[ __ ] ritorno al ritorno qua ritorno
qua vai veloce per cui colorati lato
dritto homer simpson già visto miliardo
di punti davanti ha tirato dritto va
bene me li meritavo tutti io e me li
hanno fottuti [ __ ] è aperto cioè fatta o
direttamente ragazzi sto gioco mista
mette in un'ansia è incredibile sono tre
porca vacca ma sofista bruttissima
parava va parava papà papà arca hd da
vecchi lascia stare ma solo perché se i
nano l'ha ucciso adidas sono punti i
miei di diritto questi luca non ci passa
ma cosa ma che ho affatto passata hai
fatto a poca fede
[Musica]
sono davvero davvero morto così ragazzi
ma davvero come ho fatto
così maurizio e primo maurizio che non
diventi un vizio e quello mikula i punti
che morisse il cugino male perché sono
stato io a ucciderlo brutto testa di
cazzo ti odio la famiglia ti ammazzerei
che cazzo sta succedendo sto gioco
veloce veloce veloce è più di pai
fottitene c'è uno di schiaffi di parma
non sarà mai lui che lo uccido e già che
ci sono non è morto ragazzi io non ho
parole o due volte dalla terza adesso ci
sta perché sennò mi metto a ridere la
terza di fila che muoio come un [ __ ]
e siamo a posto
mamma mia che kg fatto che chi il paura
a tutti i miei brutto deficiente coi
fottermi punti su ca non è morto è
perfetto ma ingloba ingloba inglobava
ingloba quello vuole inglobare me mentre
io voglio inglobare lui è scemo basta
cosa stia facendo sembra tipo una ultimi
qualcuni league of legends seriamente
stupido e stupido di studio c'è
veramente non ho parole che c'è uno c'è
uno c'è uno che lo ingloba mare madonna
vanto la già non sa che situazione
brutta e pieno di vermi del cazzo
perfetto attenzione che ci prova fatemi
uscire teste ricado ai debito non ci
credo eccome non è morto come non è
morto come non sta morendo
lo chiudo in mezzo se è il grande
creazione ho fatto l'ho chiuso in mezzo
a un altro verme ma c'è quello che
volevo fare con sasha nell'altro
episodio solo che non son riuscito una
volta in due d'accordo non siamo
riusciti mentre adesso da solo ci sono
riuscito come possibile siano
tredicesimi dai dai ragazzi dai ragazzi
viper vendemmia mi per vendemmia
problema a diventare primi col nome fa
vj se mi chiamo fa vj in mezzo mondo
tenta di uccidermi perché sa che sto
registrando quindi chiamarsi fa vj su
slitte rio è una versione hardcore di
slither io stesso una sezione consci che
trovavo con baci chiaro ma qualcuno ci
crepato cioè crepato c'è crepato si è
crepa tissimo vai così tanto sono
[ __ ] questi dai dai uccidilo
uccidilo non è morto che sfiga e
attenzione sì sì il cazzo questo volevo
maledizione questo vai vai vai tutti i
miei tutti i miei tutti i miei mai
questa me la sono meritata e voleva
inglobarsi tutti sto tizio o perfetto
vai vai vai veloce veloce caminotto
c'ero quasi a foto di tutti i punti
agata agata la uccido io agata non ci
arrivo miss annuncia riesce prima porca
[ __ ] non c'è ancora possibilità c'è
ancora possibilità vai vai vai vai vi
dovete togliere dai cavi dovete togliere
vermi di merda
vermi di merda dovete togliermi si
perfetto è schiantata da sola dal
fantastico entrata in ansia sono ottavo
voglio parlare a vedere no non ho visto
in finendo mi sto chiedendo ma
[ __ ]
ma come cattiva a morire così come si fa
è fresca prodotta stronza muore grande
sono miei punti lasciami in pace brutto
stronzo ma tu ma tu come neve neve neve
veloci veloci tutto differente tutto
prende tutto prendi prendi premi prima
di tutto basta faccio solo un altro
tenta uno solo e dimenticato questo è
morto grandissimo vai perfetto perfetto
perfetto ok quanto sto ventesimo ragazzi
arrivo in classifica e stavolta è quella
buona è l'ultima e non ne faccio più
perché veramente dischi di spaccare
qualcosa oggi non so perché
madonna come me la sono vista brutta
cosa ho schivato vai la schivata della
vita raga non so come ho fatto a
schivare sta roba è scemo non ha girato
ma neanche per sbaglio non andò a questo
voleva morire se un suicidio sono no che
ok ok perfetto sono ottavo ottavo dai
dai
giacché sono entrati in classifica col
mio stesso nome è impossibile è appurato
provate a chiamarvi favi james litri
augurate quant'è difficile perché mi dia
la gente ti vuole uccidere solo perché
sa che finisce nei video è morto è morto
se la schiattato anche su di me questo
perfetto testa di culo e devi togliere
volè secondi in classifica quello che
sta sopra
che culo sono vivo
non so come e vabbè è morto secondi
classifica ragazzo è molto secondi
classifica quindi sono quarto più prendo
anche i suoi punti più lì muore il cane
a quarto va bene non son riuscito a
prendere così niente di punti al naso
quarto almeno il podio almeno il podio e
lascia meli lasciami di blu lascia meli
niente quarto porca [ __ ] con l'ala si
è fatto due miliardi di punti in 3
secondi come ha fatto e attenzione però
anche a me mi butto in mezzo jolo jolo
jolo io no
di 15.000 va bene dai già qualcosa di
che ingloba tutti o inglobato inglobato
tutti fermi nativo sono tutto emozionato
che cosa prendi punti da sei morto però
che quello davanti a me pochissimi punti
ditemi voi se non riesco entrare in
podio per così poco perfetta dai dai dai
16.000 17.000 18.000 terzo sono terzo
forte 19.000 dei regolamenti mela però
c'è tagli di pam
dai che mi tre putt amiche di lavorare
della rete decadere le lei non ci faccia
a faccia barca vacca line up ha già bene
però se riescono a morire i primi due
avevo chiesto i primi due non io ei
ragazzi [ __ ] di cuore è per carità
di dio sono arrivato terzo va bene va
bene l'importante non spaccare monitor o
robe voi non lo sapete mi ha dato al mio
monitor è scheggiato perché negli scorsi
episodio lanciato le cuffie sul monitor
e si è scheggiato e [ __ ]
complimenti svizzeri o grazie un gioco
genuino accadrà che soli io ai miei
capelli super riposati
sobri vi lasciamo loro meritano online
pensarci la voce scritto like nei miei
capelli
allora che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa
che mi è piaciuto documento è un mi
piace anche a pagine di facebook con il
8 prescrizione se e solo se non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci
rivediamo ad un proseguito bello ragazzi